oh and welcome to your head good job
NORs I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast which
hasn't been very funny lately or was it
ever funny it was never funny trust me
in which we answer your questions give
you to be surprised and bring you all
the least news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John hey guy you know what's
happening to my life right now I got to
tell you I thought you usually asked how
I was doing and I have a whole bit
prepared how you doing I'm doing well I
don't know if you've ever seen the movie
Rushmore Hank there's a moment in
Rushmore where the character played by
Bill Murray says to a teenager
what's the secret max and the teenager
replies I guess you've just got to find
something you love to do and then do it
for the rest of your life for me it's
going to rush more and often in the last
10 years Hank I have felt that I have
unlocked that max Fischer secret to life
and am fortunate that it is not
attending one particular high school but
at the moment I'm a little bit jealous
of Max and his singular focus and his
ability to understand precisely what he
wants from his life I would also love a
singular focus do actual people have a
singular focus and and also is it a key
to happiness because it's well I'll tell
you what I think the guy who made
Rushmore Wes Anderson does have a
singular focus and it's making Wes
Anderson movies and I think he kind of
wakes up in the morning and that's what
he wants to do and he doesn't like
sometimes in the afternoon while he's
filming a movie he doesn't like drift
off and think maybe I'll start a
convention about podcasts speaking of
which there is very little time left to
back the pod con IndieGoGo if you go to
pod con com if you're listening to this
we use like one or two days left and or
possibly zero but there still will be
tickets available after the IndieGoGo
ends just they will be more expensive
and not all of the same things will be
available so there
a number of things that are only
available any-anything over a hundred
and twenty-five dollars is not available
after the after the convention all those
special indiegogo things but john that's
not the the thing that is exciting me
right now
certainly it's something I'm working on
and I am excited about it but not as
exciting is the fact that I just got a
microscope oh I have a microscope
hey do you oh it's amazing so good dude
look up close at the world it looks
totally different it's also do I got I I
got really obsessed with a fabric
recently John and I wanted to know
everything about it and so I've been
doing a lot of research about fabric but
one of the problems is like like you
know I want to know what what how thing
why things feel different and why they
are different and and like and but one
shirt feels different from another one
and your pants feel different from your
sheets and all that stuff and so I've
been doing too much research but it's
like there's just not some like you
can't do it all until you actually get
to look at it like there's like reading
about it but then looking at it and a
lot of the stitching is so fine these
days that you can't really look at it
without a microscope so I got a
microscope specifically just to look at
fabric and I feel like this is my
singular focus this is my going to
Rushmore and all I want to do is look at
fabric and talk to people about how
textiles work this so I can surprise you
Hank but when I got a microscope the
very first thing that I did was prick my
finger and look at the blood mmm I did
look I did do something that randall
munroe of xkcd suggests you never do
which is look at the undersides of your
fingernails which I did and I agree
don't do that yeah that sounds
disgusting no I found looking at my
blood very helpful though because I was
looking at like you know these millions
of cells or I don't know how many in a
single drop of blood like as I moved the
slide around and I just remember
thinking like I bet these cells all
think that they are important and
interesting in precisely the same way I
do that is not the case John I can
guarantee you your blood cells don't
have
don't know anything they're not even
they're not even I don't think you could
actually guarantee that let's get to a
question from our listeners Hank I don't
have a short poem for the day this
question comes from Joey it is very
important and we need to get to it
quickly Joey writes I came home from
work today and my front and back yard
had been mowed what should I do
should I be freaked out it was a little
tall with some weeds and things but not
to such a degree that I should be on the
receiving end of some kind of lawn care
vigilantism right yours and discomfort
Joey don't go in my yard with your yep I
have a story I have a story too
I want you go first I may have I may
have stole this told the story on the
podcast or somewhere before because it
oh my goodness so I used to live in a
house that was a rental and and there
were three units and and one day my
landlord was hanging out and he was like
hey did you pull up the flowers that
were back behind the fence and I was
like no I didn't pull up any of your
flowers no I don't do like voluntary
yard work and then another of my
neighbors like came out into the back
porch area and and he was like hey did
you pull up those the flowers that were
back by the fence and the guy was like
those weeds and my dad was like no that
the flowers that were back there and he
was like there was some weeds that I
pulled and melon orders like well they
were wild flowers from seeds that were
thrown at my wedding
he obviously lived in this house before
he started renting it out and the guy
was like I don't know what you're
talking about but I I pulled up some I
pulled up some weeds yeah and the
landlord is like well they were flowers
and I and you know we'll do the yard
maintenance like that's on me the
landlord not on you the tenant and the
guy was like well now you just make me
feel bad well I mean I don't know it
sounds to me like those I was to to
awkward people here's my story when I
first moved in to it when I first moved
to Indianapolis I was so excited to have
a lawn I've been telling we'd been
living in New York I've been telling
Sarah for months that when we moved to
Indianapolis I was gonna buy a lawnmower
and be a
pneumos their lawn every Saturday and it
was gonna make me so happy and at the
end of mowing my lawn I was gonna drink
I don't know Miller High Life or
whatever it is the proper of normal
Americans in the middle of the country
drink and I was just gonna buy all in on
being a lawn guy and about we lived
there for about six weeks and I was
mowing the lawn one day and I mean it's
just hell I don't
it's it's just as close to Hell as I've
ever come to mow alone and then to have
the grass grow again and then you just
think man I haven't walked on that lawn
since the last time I mowed it and now
I'm gonna have to walk on it again only
to mow it all summer long so anyway a
mowing the lawn there's like this ditch
between my my yard and my neighbor's
yard and my neighbor only mows up to his
end of the ditch even though he has a
riding lawnmower and I'm like have this
like you know this push thing that's
battery-powered because it's better for
the environment or whatever but it's
just not even very good lawn mower and
the guy comes up to me my next door
neighbor comes up to me puts his arm
around me I turn off the stupid lawn
mower puts his arm around me and he says
you know when the Kaufman's lived here
this was the best lawn in the
neighborhood oh and you and I said to
him Hank something I'm sure very nice I
said listen buddy unless you want to be
Joey's neighbor doing some lawn care
vigilantism back the eff off the
Kaufman's don't live here anymore you
got the green family there's some things
were good at art writing for teenagers
[Laughter]
paint colors and then there's some
things that we're not good at like
mowing the lawn oh I was so mad and I
bye I mean here's the thing Joey uh
altum Utley I think you should be
grateful and then the other thing I
think you should do
is definitely do not mow your lawn for a
couple weeks because it's possible that
this lawn care thing will be a regular
occurrence like maybe somebody really
loves mowing their lawn and they loved
it so much that when they're done mowing
their lawn there they look over and they
think you know Joey's lawn could use a
mowing and then they just go over there
and do it and then they drink their
Miller High Life and they're so happy so
why would you make them unhappy by
telling them that they can't mow your
lawn anymore I have a back door neighbor
who snow blows off my car so when this
one likes like a bunch of snow falls he
has a snow blower like yeah leaf blower
basically and he's doing his car and
then he goes and does my car and I've
never told him to do it I've never asked
him to do it yeah but I have thanked him
for doing it and it just happens and
it's not and I think he just I think he
just likes it he also like he's like he
is in fact a lawn care professional that
guy and he has he has a bill Wow and I
see him on the Billboard and then I see
him in my backyard and I'm like there he
is that guy I forgot his name
I mean ability Hank yes only remembers
Dale its names never their actual name
just the docs a professional lawn care
service has begun mowing Joey's yard and
in a couple weeks Joey is just gonna get
an invoice and in that situation Joey I
would recommend that you pay that
invoice and continue to enjoy this lawn
care finish it's nice that you didn't
have to set it up it just sort of
automatically happened though if you
don't want to pay for lawn care you
don't have to just because someone has
has mowed your lawn without you asking
my goodness my goodness this question is
from Sarah who asks sometimes I find
myself in a position of having to share
a quote fun fact about myself oh yeah
and the prospect of sharing a single fun
fact about myself to be somewhat
intimidating since it's often the first
impression I make to a group of people
is it better to attempt to use my fun
fact to come across as funny and
interesting or should I try to make the
fun fact as forgettable as
possible so that I get an opportunity to
make a first impression later on tell us
a fun fact about yourselves Sara I mean
I just I hate that question so much
not the not Sara's question but but tell
me a fun fact about you right I hate
being asked to tell a fun fact about
myself yeah I John you know what I'm
actually really good at the fun fact
round two what is Hank tell me a fun
fact about yourself uh uh you know I
invented 2d glasses and in 1998 I was
voted winter park icicles best answer I
mean that's true it's not it's not the
world's fault that most of us didn't
invent 2d glasses and most of us were
not named best answer at Winter Park
High School in 1998 I mean Hank has a
huge advantage in this topic because he
is he is the subject of so many
incredibly fun facts that's nice of you
to say that's that makes me feel why
actually just to be clear I'm not
totally sure that's a compliment
I actually the most recent time I did
this was in like birth class and I
actually did a really bad job I tried I
wanted to try out something out
something new so I like instead of
saying like a fun fact about myself I
kind of just talked about like what I
was into it kind of in the hopes that I
would find somebody else who was into
the same things so I said yeah I'm
really into hard science fiction and I
don't know though everybody in the room
knew what that even was but not a fun
fact no one in the room was also into
hard science fiction I was basically
looking for some other dad who's gonna
have a kid the same age as mine first
kid and we're gonna be like besties but
alas it was a bunch of Missoula Montana
hiker and snowboarder folk because
that's who that's who lives here
but yeah so here's what I want to say to
Sara I have a Sarah thing so first thing
you got to know is that if you go first
or second like nobody's gonna hear what
you say because everybody is way too
busy thinking of their own fun fact
that's true and in fact that's true you
know maybe you maybe you want to make it
if you
maybe you want to make sure that you go
first or second so that no one will
remember your fun fact and then make it
just an outrageous lie so it could be
like my fun fact is that on the set of
the movie lala land I had a brief but
extremely intense affair with Ryan
Gosling we aren't seeing each other
anymore
but for those 48 hours I have never felt
so loved who's next
oh god my fun fact is that my
great-great grandfather designed the
penny that's great oh my god I don't
even know if that's Hank for all I know
that's true and we have the same great
great very well be true yeah yep we have
several we have I mean if you put
another great on there there's like 35
potential people that's good okay let's
all let's actually you know what Hank
let's all just agree to use that fact no
matter what so that way you'll know if
you're ever in a fun fact situation
you'll know if you meet another listener
of dear Hank and John they'll be like my
fun fact is that my great-great
grandfather designed the penny and then
you'll be like you listen to dear Hank
and John and then they'll be like oh no
no no my great-great grandfather
designed the penny I don't know what
you're talking about
my great Lincoln he put his own face on
the penny my great great grandfather
Abraham Lincoln pressed the side of his
face against a huge piece of copper and
what resulted from that was a coinage
that ought to not exist how long have we
even had that have we had the penny for
as long as we've had a dollar because
like how have we had this thing for so
long through so long how long how long
before penny Hank Hank let me tell you
how long we've had the penny do you want
to know how long we've had the penny how
long we've had the penny so long that
when the penny was first became the
smallest piece of coinage available it
was worth more than today's quarter Wow
what I'm telling you is that a hundred
and thirty years ago they survived with
it with the lowest lowest coin available
being worth a quarter and the world did
not fall apart and the economy did not
suffer and nothing terrible happened
because pennies and nickels and arguably
dimes are just not good they should not
exist we should move on to another
question this one is from Addison who
asks dear John and Hank John you
frequently state that you were a
Christian I wouldn't say I frequently
stated but okay if you believe that
one's faith has eternal consequences as
most Christians do then why are you so
okay with Hanks lack of faith Hank how
do you get along so well with a brother
who has such a different worldview from
you one foot in the grave Addison I mean
so yeah I've never asked where do you
think I'm I mean what am I gonna go I
mean we're laughing and that might be
disrespectful and I apologize if it
comes across as disrespectful yeah hi
yeah so I I'm not totally sure I agree
with the assessment that most Christians
believe that one's faith has eternal
consequences partly because the Catholic
Church has been pretty what's the
technical term for it I think
wishy-washy on the subject of whether
only Catholics go to heaven and I think
in this point after vatican ii it's
pretty clear that the catholic church
does not hold that only only catholics
go to heaven uh as for me personally
like I often say that I I think the
question of whether God like quote
unquote really exists is one of the
least interesting questions in in
religion to me and also like one of the
least interesting questions in my own
personal faith I also AM not very
interested in the question of
whether there is an afterlife or what
that afterlife would look like or who it
would include or exclude but I am not in
any way worried about Hanks eternal soul
it's just not it's just not my that's
just not my theology I guess it's just
not the way that I mean everybody
everybody constructs a certain theology
that hopefully to them like make sense
and is consistent and can be applied in
all situations and and doesn't have you
know huge gaping holes in it and I've
worked hard to kind of build a faith
that I think works for me on that front
but I do not I am not worried about Hank
soul I think Hank is a good person and I
think that I think he's good I think
he'll be fine
yeah I mean it's it's I appreciate you
answering this question when I saw it I
was like I would like to hear John's
answer to this question but I'd also of
course didn't want to like point like
point you wouldn't like say like hi you
have to answer this now but thanks for
asking it I send thank you John for
answering I am I do in general like like
as a person who does not have a faith I
often find it weird how focused we get
on these questions that seem to me kind
of I don't know I don't want to say
pedantic but a little like just a little
bit like there there is a much bigger
set of questions here about how to be a
person and the and like the get getting
focused on the places where we disagree
when we agree on what I think are much
more important things that's how I get
along with people who have quote a
different worldview for me because we
don't have a different worldview we have
a different understanding of like of
like like the Chi like the nature of the
cosmos a little bit but but in terms of
how to act and be a person I think that
that I think that like we we did we
agree on more than like you know most
people I have ever met
so that's how I get along well with my
brother it
yeah I mean the analogy that I use and
I'll of course always be suspicious of
analogies especially bees
Joseph's analogies when it comes to
religion but the analogy that I use is
imagine that someone is screaming your
house is on fire in that situation I am
NOT very interested in who's screaming
my house is on fire
like I it maybe it is God maybe it is a
fireman the relevant issue to me is that
the house is on fire but my my religious
faith basically comes from a belief that
that I have been informed by by God
through through Holy Scriptures that
that the house is on fire and I'm trying
my best to respond to that what I would
call like revelation but I also
understand that lots of people wouldn't
call that a revelation and if they're
interested in responding to the house
being on fire situation I welcome their
input and assistance you know like I I I
don't I don't think we should sit here
and have it like how many angels can we
fit on the head of a pin conversation I
think we should have a conversation that
begins like hey what are we gonna do
about the fact that the house is on fire
yeah and I yeah well in this specific
situation of of the afterlife I I don't
tend to be affected too much by how what
people think is gonna happen to my me
whatever I am after I die because of
course in my worldview
nothing will happen for a long long time
just like nothing happened for a long
long time before I existed and it's just
as sad that I wasn't around for all
those billions of years that I won't be
around for the next billions but so
that's a bummer I don't think it's all
sad though I mean I like I would I love
I mean I agree with you I totally agree
with you but I but like I just I feel
like I've gotten to see so many amazing
things happen and this short little
blink that I've been alive I'm gonna and
I like it sad to me that I'm gonna miss
so many amazing things that are gonna
happen in the future and that happened
in the
and also that are happening right now
and then I'll never know about because
they don't speak the right language or
don't live in the right place or I don't
know about that like I don't have the
same cultural background to allow me to
enjoy it in the same way there's just
like we miss out on everything that is
that is Lea the definition of being a
human is missing out on stuff but but
but you know there's a the side effect
of appreciating the things that I that
I'm really into whether it's microscope
in my pants or hanging out with my
brother is that I feel like I will I
will be missing out on things after I am
gone so I want to read you this quote by
Toni Morrison and I agree with you you
know at the end of his life Maurice
Sendak the author of where the wild
things are said in an in an interview I
have fallen in love with the world and I
think that there is something really
magical about falling in love with the
world because you missed this or you
missed that and you miss almost
everything but you don't miss everything
if you can fall in love with the world
but this quote from Toni Morrison is
something that I think about a lot in
that context Hank it's a she wrote at
some point in life the world's beauty
becomes enough you don't need to
photograph paint or even remember it
it is enough and speaking of that John I
have a question it comes from John who
asks dear Hank and John how does one get
into the ice-cream truck business that
is right on topic because the ice cream
business is also a way of falling in
love with the world
maybe maybe uh so the first thing of
course that you have to do is you've got
to you've got to acquire an ice cream
truck and a lot of ice now like he also
like well you don't I don't think you
even need an ice cream truck John you
just need a cooler strapped to your bike
but you do need ice cream and you need
ice cream and you need some way of
keeping it extremely cold nobody's gonna
buy you know a choco taco that's half
milk or all melt it's like yeah nobody's
gonna buy ice cream that isn't ice it's
just like sweet milk
that's gonna sell Alice my daughter
might buy that actually she'd be into it
it's like warm sweet milk um yeah
Hank how much do you know about the ice
cream business is this one of like an
area of expertise I'm gonna be surprised
to learn about uh well I do want to say
so John John also asked about a number
of like technical like is do you like
work for someone else when you have an
ice cream truck or they're all
independent and it's variety there there
are some people who own a bunch of ice
cream trucks that usually this starts by
someone having one and then expanding
their little empire and hiring people to
run them but most ice cream trucks are
independent businesses they are
sometimes franchises so you can you can
get a franchise license for an existing
ice cream truck business and they'll
help you figure out your business model
there are also places where you can just
look up online to see like what's the
business model of an ice cream truck and
how does it work and how do you know if
yours is going to be successful or not
but yeah you for the most part they are
independent businesses and it is not a
not a way to make a killing like you're
not gonna get wealthy as an ice cream
truck person but you you might work for
yourself and and make enough to go and
and do it just fine but you do need some
startup capital and that's that is the
the you know the the barrier in most
business like you need enough money to
buy an ice cream truck and to get those
speakers on the top that play the music
and and to get it and to get a good ice
cream supplier which there's a number of
ways to do that as well to get to get an
expensive wholesale ice cream but yeah
so you can it's possible it's a thing
that people do and can do I don't know
if it's a thing that is a growth field
though does it feel a little bit like
people don't trust ice cream trucks
anymore uh maybe a little bit but then I
don't think people trust most of the
major institutions like I'm concerned
about people not trusting ice cream
trucks as much as they used to I'm
significantly more concerned about
people not trusting democracy as much as
they used to speaking of which Hank we
got a question from Jethro who writes up
but by the way Hank thank you for that
really
interesting introduction to the business
of ice cream truck sales I was not
something that I thought we would ever
get into around here Dear John and aq
were both lucky enough to interview and
in one case meet former President of the
United States Barack Obama if you were
given the opportunity to interview and
meet the current president would you
take it and what would you ask
Tinka t-talk old fruit and down the
nazis Jethro PS apparently this is how
the Queen Mother used to sign off her
correspondence British again
Brent Rennicks hashtag Britain
oh well you know they've got they've got
a similar set of issues to us John it
turns out and I wouldn't say that
similar that I wouldn't say that similar
for a little bit of context Hank I there
are a number of people in Britain who
have I heart the NHS tattooed on their
bodies I would I would ask you very
sincerely mmm is there an American with
I heart the American healthcare system
tattooed on their bodies no but I do I
do I do feel like maybe that is a that
is a future like like something that
appeals to me a little bit like getting
my bike my positions just tattooed on my
body somewhere like climate change is
real all right
but to the question yeah to the question
to the question to the question what was
the question would you interview
President Trump Oh what would you ask
right I forgot what it was because I
didn't want to answer the question I
don't think that I would yeah I like it
like in all honesty like I think that
there's a funny answer to this question
that I didn't that I didn't go to but
it's hard for me to be funny around this
topic right now yeah I know I don't I
don't I don't think I I don't think I
would like uh if I did if I if I like
gotten to a headspace where I I wanted
to I I feel like I would probably only
ask him one question and I would ask it
over and over again and I don't know
what
would be but it would just be a number
of any of the things that he says all
the time that is just patently untrue
like like like over and over again he
said it's very difficult for a
Republican to win with the electoral
college in place and I just want to know
what he means by that because it's not
true it is more difficult for Democrats
to win because Republicans are over
represented by the electoral college
like rural areas are over represented by
the electoral college and I'm not saying
that like that you know rural areas
shouldn't like represent the you know
their physical space that they are in
and get some extra representation
because because of how you know states
like this is the United States of
America but that's it's like I'm not
arguing it's the Electoral College I
think that there's a place for that we
don't need to do that right now I just
want to know what he means
cuz like what does he think he's saying
and wouldn't like whenever he says it
it's just like there's so many other
things to argue about that are much
bigger like it's just over and over
again I just like when it be like can we
just get to the point where we're like
you're like okay yeah no I get it I'm
just saying stuff that that's that's I'm
making up just making stuff up cuz it
sounds good well so I actually think
that that's part of a strategy to get
you to ask questions like that instead
of to enrage on other topics and so it
would sort of be a win for for him right
and and probably like he would just that
like the the strategy seems to be to be
like well you know like get a little bit
flustered and be like well if you don't
if you don't know what I mean then right
like I'm not gonna tell you right and so
yeah I mean like I am legitimately
curious about some things but I think I
think that you were right that it like I
just don't think that it's productive
because he like there just isn't like
you don't like it was amazing like I
asked for a rock obama about his
position on legalizing marijuana like
over and like the next day his answer
was news it was like like he said
something that he hadn't previously said
right that was like insightful and and
and was sort of a path forward and and
like an understanding of like
the slow process that we have to go
through in order for this to eventually
happen and I was like what what it like
like news was made rather than just
being like well we can't really like it
doesn't really matter what this guy says
because he says something different the
next day yeah that's one of the reasons
I would choose not to interview the
president
the biggest reason honestly is that it
would stress me out and it would not be
that fun and I don't think that it would
so I would spend a lot of time worrying
about it but I don't think that it would
move the needle in u.s. political
discourse in any way I don't think
there's anything that I could say that
would move the needle because we're all
to quote Robert Penn Warren just bubbles
on the tide of empire and so why stress
myself out for three weeks about
something that won't matter and when I
had the chance to do it with President
Obama I kind of felt the same way but I
also felt like there were a couple of
questions that I could ask that would be
meaningful to me and that then he
responded I thought to both of them
quite thoughtfully uh-huh let's answer a
couple more coit wait wait wait wait
wait wait what what what hey what I've
just I've just received an email oh
that's weird that you're looking at your
email right now it's from the American
Quarter Oh from the quarter from the
unit of currency today's podcast is
brought to you by a brand new sponsor
one American quarter the last coin that
should exist other than maybe dollar
coins I own completely think dollar
coins should exist and I appreciate this
sponsorship and I assume that they sent
us three hundred seventy eight quarters
which is not a paltry sum John it's mmm
yeah it's not paltry I wouldn't say it's
poultry it's definitely not a poultry
some this podcast is also brought to you
by lawn care vigilantism lawn care
vigilantism not technically two words
that are words definitely one of them I
think it's vigilantism mmm it doesn't
matter it we we've read the sponsors
however they come in Hank if they want
to be lawn care vigilantism that's fine
and of course there's black guys it's
true I did did not me to judge Vaughn
care today's podcast is also brought to
you by Hank Sol which is just fine
and finally this five guest is brought
to you by John's ice cream truck
business an independent source for all
of your delicious warm sweet milks I
think the only thing just to go back to
a previous point I even in saying that I
think your soul is fine I fear that I
might have offended you by implying that
you have a soul so I'm sorry if that if
that hurt your feelings but I do think
that you have a soul and we are that is
probably something that we do disagree
about but it's not a big deal to us but
I apologize for implying that you have
an actual soul yeah I do not mind you
thinking I have a soul like this is not
a thing that bothers me
great I'm gonna keep thinking it I'm
Wonder I don't know exactly why it
doesn't bother me but lot lots of people
think things that I don't think that
don't have a negative effect on me or
the world I don't know yeah I think
that's great
I think it's good I like I like that I
like that we don't agree about
everything but I actually think that
that is one of our less interesting
disagreements we've got really good
proper disagreements about for instance
whether the movie Rushmore is important
to see tomorrow I I do I'd I will watch
Rushmore John and in fact I would like
to watch it with you if that's if that's
ever possible I think that that would be
fun I'd be great I would love to watch
it with you but it's gonna be a little
annoying because I mouths every line of
dialogue as it happens then all right
this question comes from Denny who
writes Dear John and Hank I don't know
what's happening but whenever gunnarolla
kicks in is I'm listening on overcast I
get a smile and pep up I can't wait for
the poem of the day oh I'm sorry to
disappoint your dinner get news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon and listen to the
rest of the dubious advice that you to
dole out in short your podcast is a
highlight of my podding week the problem
is I'm almost 60 years old not your
target audience does this mean I'm going
through a midlife crisis
quick pause nope no let's finish the
question before I deliver it deliver the
hammer should I just stick with NPR and
act my age should I buy a Ferrari
deadpans and
right so nice one that's a great sign
off dead pants and bedpans I mean that's
like not since the Queen mom have I
heard a sign off of that well one
question I can only guess that Dinny is
British just like I desperately want to
be again what what's what's the hammer
Johnny what are you gonna crush down I
think it's a little late to talk about
midlife crises I feel very strongly that
the term middle-aged has been
inappropriately hijacked by people who
are not middle-aged
I am middle-aged because if you double
my age it is an acceptable if not ideal
life span I will continue to be
middle-aged until I'm about 47 at which
point I will become and this is a phrase
I have just made up I hope that it
catches on young old yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like young adult but young old
person right instead of being a young
adult which I was when I was 17 yeah
when I'm 50 to 60 mm eight I will be
young old then from like 68 to 80 I'll
be old and then from 80 to hopefully 136
you'll be dead and then after 136 you
will also be dead no after that they're
gonna use the cryogenic technology to
bring me back and I'm gonna be better
than ever
well I do want to say to Denny some
people have lived to be a hundred and
twenty years old by which I mean one
person ever has lived to be a hundred
and twenty years actually you know what
maybe that's a good point hang on is is
middle-aged I take it back
Denny good news your middle age don't
buy a Ferrari it's just not a good use
of your resources I mean quick pause to
note that if you can afford to buy a
Ferrari you can probably afford to head
over to patreon comment and John and
throw this podcast sometimes you want to
have your midlife crisis on patreon
really like that yeah
you know if you're gonna spend a Ferrari
level money on something we can get you
some amazing perks you can get access to
this week in Ryan's we I mean I for a
Ferrari I will make you your own podcast
Hank I desperately want you to own a
Ferrari and I want you to own a Ferrari
that you are not allowed to sell oh that
is the first thing I would do with a
Ferrari and that you are not allowed to
transfer to any other human being and
also as a condition of you owning this
Ferrari I might buy it for you as a
condition of you owning this Ferrari it
would be the only car you would be
allowed to drive around the streets of
Missoula Montana my god oh god I have
such a hang-up about this stuff John
like me to the like imagining myself in
an expensive car like a and and like it
makes me realize that when I look at
people who drive cars like that like
when I'm in Beverly Hills and I see like
Aston Martin's driving around like I
look inside those cars and I'm like I
don't judge people super harshly all the
time but right now you are dirt to me
like they own is a disgusting choice I
just know like I have a very hard time
imagining people spending two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars on a car for
any other reason than like being really
hung up on this I like these weird ideas
of wealth and also wanting to just throw
it out there at other people and what
could possibly and how disconnected do
you have to be from reality to spend
that to just evaporate that all of that
power that you have a couple things
saying this thing that isn't that serves
you in no way commensurate with its with
its cost okay couple things first off
please stop alienating our most likely
big dollar sponsors Jesus get your head
out of your behind these people when it
comes project for awesome time we need
them when it comes time to sponsor a new
series of crash
course Hank yeah Hank the weird rich
people are the people we depend upon the
most leave weird whenever I see one of
those cars well and let they're already
leading the way whenever I see one of
those cars I try to tell myself okay is
it not possible that this person has one
singular tremendous passion which is the
magic of automotive engineering and they
are trying to push it forward through
this purchase and it is so important to
them and it is the thing that gets them
up in the morning the way that I love
AFC Wimbledon which I also waste a ton
of money on
I wouldn't say waste I would say in this
like is might it not be their AFC
Wimbledon a thing that gives them joy
and structure and meaning in a place
where they really struggle to find it
and so I try not that's how I try not to
judge them so I'm just saying Denny
if you want to buy a Ferrari which by
the way it sounds like you don't really
way off the question if you've want to
buy a Ferrari you know just have a good
long think about it but it sounds to be
a question like you definitely don't the
question is is it is it socially
acceptable to be a sixty-year-old fan of
dear Hank and John and the answer is
overwhelmingly unambiguously yes yes yes
thank you think that is awesome it made
it made our day that's why we read your
question and had a fight about expensive
cars like and I I definitely don't feel
like there's anything about this podcast
it's like particularly youth-oriented
right hmm no in fact we devoted like
half of an episode to Kokomo the Beach
Boys song by the way Hank we might have
gotten five hundred emails about coke I
everyone has apologized all the people
who felt less than human because they
felt excluded because we thought that
they didn't like or listened to Kokomo
that is our bad our bad we're sorry
Kokomo has had many lives in many forms
since it was first released and so in a
lot of children's meat
especially like there's a chipmunks
Kokomo there's a Muppets Kokomo so
there's lots of coca for people to
consume as children whether or not they
were born in the 80s speaking of which I
need to get system Corrections real
quickly before we get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon we have some
vital Corrections this week we got at
least one vital correction we have three
vital Corrections and several others
that were not going to get to because of
time Kevin wrote in to say my son and I
were listening to your pod he's a pilot
in training he tells me that when planes
crashed their tail numbers can be reused
for other airplanes but all crashes are
still tied to that tail number so that
likely means that the young person who
was born in an airplane was born in an
airplane that had not crashed which is
probably it's a good news for her we are
not in a sliding doors multiverse
situation also Kevin and Christian
salika point out that the steering wheel
is not called a steering wheel on an
airplane it is called a yoke also I
received an email from baito who wrote
dear brothers green in a recent episode
of the pod you talked about rodents and
at some point John mentioned how there
were no rodents larger than a baby at
which point Hank corrected him saying
how wrong he was and then of course I
freaked out and just kept saying nope
and stop telling me about these rodents
now baito points out I was born and
raised in Venezuela and as a proud
Venezuelan I cannot let this slide the
biggest rodent in the world the capybara
is native to Venezuela and Brazil and is
in my opinion one of the cutest freakin
animals there are with all that is
happening in my country I believe we
have enough bad rep as it is I mean Hank
is laughing but bado seriously I am
deeply sorry and deeply concerned about
what is happening in Venezuela right now
and then Bator sent three amazing
pictures of these rodents that they look
nothing like rats
they look like lovable huggable dogs
with rodent faces and I have completely
fallen in love with them and I just want
to stay safe entirely for the record I
was wrong I was wrong I was wrong we're
gonna post these to the patreon they're
very kyoto oh my gosh
there's Hank do you want to read the
Star Wars one because it was fascinating
so our final correction is from
anonymous who does not want to it let
everybody know about who they are dear
Hank and John big fan of the pot in a
recent episode Hank discussed various
clothing clasp mechanisms of Star Wars
and how they appear to have all the same
technologies that we have here on earth
however I have worked with the Star Wars
license and I have even had the
privilege of creating characters that
occupy the expanded universe this is
very cool that this person listens to
the pod
during this pot during this process we
act during this process we actually got
a lot of notes regarding concepts
phrases and items that don't exist in
the Star Wars universe examples include
the term refresher instead of bathroom
and the conspicuous absence of ordinary
paper products do they also not have
paper products in the bathrooms Tezz do
they have the three seashells because I
still want to know how those work at any
rate there are no bathrooms Hank oh just
yeah that is where they do shoes right
sorry sorry no toilet paper and there
refreshers at any and then he at any
rate I'm here to inform you that in a
galaxy far far away there are no
shoelaces during the development of our
product we were instructed to alter a
particular character's combat boots to
remove any trace of boot laces and
replace them with straps since one can
find the occasional cord in a Star Wars
garment I am given to imagine that the
restriction is largely limited to aglet
technology so that's the holes that the
laces go through so while I find it out
what that's not what an aglet is oh it's
an aglet an aglet is the little thing at
the end of the shoelace oh that's super
weird somebody hasn't watched every
episode of Phineas and Ferb okay go on
so while I find it hard to imagine um so
while I find it hard to imagine a more
truly trivial piece of trivia there it
is costumes and cannons anonymous that
was fascinating and Navi notice an epic
piece of trivia don't be surprised if
that pops up in something that I write
someday but yes that is an epic piece of
trivia speaking of epic Hank what's the
news for Mars on the surface of Mars
John yeah
there is a fish mm-hmm what really I me
that is I've got finally some proper
news from Mars I just I was checking to
see if you're listening and you totally
weren't because you just said mm-hmm and
then like no it took me a second it just
took me a second
so there are so there is a paper that
just came out about what they are
calling halos and they are basically
these areas of lighter geography around
fissures in the end in and around Gale
Crater which is this ancient lake bed
that definitely had water in it for
hundreds of thousands of years
consecutively at the beginning of Mars's
history and then was all gone by about
3.5 ish billion years ago so that's
where Curiosity rover is at
and so there's getting lots of very good
interesting I said hundreds of thousands
of years I think I meant to say hundreds
of millions of years consecutively so
this is like the like fairly new
information that curiosity has given us
that this was a lake bed for a long long
time long long time but by 3.5 billion
years ago ish it seems like all that was
gone but these halos are indicating that
while it was no longer a lake bed there
was at times
flowing water that was laying down these
silica sediments which is that what
causes the light color and and that
would have been groundwater seepage it
may have been like precipitation running
like rooting down in review it's but
probably it was groundwater related and
and that that groundwater would
occasionally come up to the surface and
then leave behind the silica on the
surface and that was happening for much
longer now that they haven't made any
like super statements about how much
longer but we're talking a significant
extension of Mars's sort of habitable
period where there would have been
liquid water either on the surface or
very near the surface that that biology
could have continued existing in so it's
fairly it's a new paper just came out
and miss exciting stuff that is cool I
mean it's still not quite the same thing
as a fish on Mars no no there's there's
there's not a fish as far as we know but
if there was a fish it would not be on
Mars it would definitely have to be
somewhere in because or just dead could
just be at like somebody like somebody
just threw through a fish really hard
and it hit Mars I mean really hard tank
do you know where I was uh one year ago
today were you at the Indianapolis 500
no I wasn't at the Indianapolis 500
because I had already left the
Indianapolis 500 to fly to London to
attend the play-off final right between
AFC Wimbledon and mmm I don't Plymouth
Plymouth Plymouth Argyle Football Club
who by the way Hank got promoted this
year from league two so even though they
suffered heartbreak at Wembley a year
ago today they have they have since gone
up which is wonderful news very happy
for them but of course here in the
Wimbledon fan community we have all been
reliving that magical day where Lyle
Taylor the the Messi for Montserrat the
Christiano Ronaldo of the Caribbean
scored a vital goal to put the Dons 1
nil up and then Auto bio Aachen phenoix
with the last kick of his AFC Wimbledon
career scored a penalty to secure a to
nil victory AFC Wimbledon went up to
Ligue 1 where of course they finished
15th this year having not scored a
league goal in April which when you
combine those two facts is pretty
impressive and on the topic of not
scoring a legal in April they they have
just signed a new striker who's also
kind of an old striker he used to play
on loan for four AFC Wimbledon and his
name is Kwesi Appiah
or a Piatt I actually don't know how to
pronounce it but he had a good loan
spell for AFC Wimbledon when he was last
with the Dons and I'm very excited and
hopeful and it is very likely that he
has signed because word on the street is
the Tom Elliot with the most successful
striker for this season's AFC Wimbledon
is like
headed to the championship he is gonna
be headed to a team that just got
promoted from Ligue 1 up to the
championship which is great news for him
but because he's out of contract with
AFC Wimbledon Wimbledon won't get a fee
I don't think for that which is on for
that move which is unfortunate but it is
good news for Tom and and Wimbledon want
to be the kind of club where people are
so successful that they can play in
higher leagues although of course we
would have liked to hang on to him so
that's the update it's it's been a
wonderful amazing year for AFC Wimbledon
and hopefully with this new signing it
will be one more step toward an even
better season next year although frankly
any staying up would be a victory next
year so well that's that is exciting did
you did you hear that that that there
were some game worn clothes from those
that that final thing being sold on AFC
Bay do you know about AFC Bay no wow
what is AFC Bay is that like it an eBay
site that they do yeah no it's an eBay
site that they do and they they have a
bunch of stuff and I recently got
something it wasn't from that playoff
game but I did get a pair of AFC
Wimbledon shorts oh are you
oh that have that have the logo on it or
were worn by Lyle Taylor in a game
because I thought that that would be oh
that's great thanks man that was nice of
you I'm excited - very excited to frame
those shorts yeah that's pretty cool
that we got that dftba going on them and
then we get to actually I'm excited to
actually see them I haven't seen them
yeah so yeah they're pretty great in
real life I can't wait to take you over
to England for a game I know it's harder
now that you've got the kid and
everything but uh yeah John I want to
thank a couple people I want to thank
Roxanna for getting the the the $25
remote attendance perk for pod con and I
want to thank Bret for getting the $90
actual attendance in Seattle perk and
also I want to thank Parker for getting
the hundred and fifty dollar level which
includes a swag bag and
so a magical thumb drive that has a
bunch of things that the founders of POD
Khan are creating and also a list a
collection of some of our very favorite
podcasts that have ever existed so
thanks to those folks if you want to
support pod Khan in the final days
before we end we end it on Tuesday so
this goes up on Monday so the Tuesday
after this goes up that IndieGoGo will
be ending and then pod con comm will
become a website where you can get
slightly more expensive and more limited
tickets until we actually have a pod con
which will happen December 9th and 10th
in Seattle and I'm looking forward to
live dear Hank and John in from there
and also doing a bunch of other weird
interesting fun and cool things hey John
yeah but what do we learn today well we
learned that Hank knows a surprising
amount or pretended to anyway about how
to build an ice cream truck business I
just
I've always obsessed with I really want
to make like a ice cream trucks but it's
Donuts so I thought a good idea but
thought about it that's a good idea
because here in Montana this did not
know how to call for ice cream all year
round right we also learned that the
penny was designed by Abraham Lincoln
just lit linking just smashing his face
into into a giant metal plate oh yeah
that is that is I believe now a
historical fact that's how facts
happened now Hank you just repeat them
over and over again and then they become
fact and of course we learned that if
somebody is mowing your lawn just just
roll with it man and finally we learned
that if you are 60 years old there is a
very small chance that you will reach
the age of 120 and you will at at 60 be
middle aged which is pretty remarkable
that that has ever happened to to be
clear only one person ever yeah but I
believe that it's gonna start happening
all the time this we're on that we're on
the very brink of curing aging if
Silicon Valley weirdo billionaires are
to be believed we also learned that
aglet has nothing to do with the holes
in shoes it's the thing that wraps it up
and when I
that Phineas and Ferb was the second
thing after Wikipedia that comes well
they've got a whole song about it Hank
and after you listen you will never
forget what an aglet is thanks everybody
for listening to our podcast you can
find us on Twitter at Hank green and
John Green and you can email us your
questions at Hank and John at gmail.com
we always welcome your questions and are
very grateful for them we apologize to
all the ones we didn't get to also if
you can't get enough dear Hank and John
we have a new supplemental podcast
called this week in Ryan's where every
week we talked about a different Ryan
you can find out more about that at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
this podcast is produced by rosianna
halse rojas and sheridan Gibson it's
edited by nicholas jenkins our social
media person is Victoria bonne journee
who also helps that with the patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John the
music that you hear now and at the
beginning of podcast is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]